what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting to kevin
samuels
funny moments before i start do not
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos
just a reminder my goal for the channel
this month is to hit 20 000 subscribers
so if you don't mind
hit that subscribe button and
help me get there okay
make this let me tell you what i'm
calling in so when i heard yeah you call
in to put the
put the girls on the camera
damn but you know what i do know is this
how you act on the phone
you are tripping a relationship
and i've tried to be really nice to you
for acting the way you do bucking your
eyes and [ __ ]
this is live people are looking okay so
i'm gonna get off live
because i feel like you're being a
little outrageous
but thank you so much damn yeah you
don't come over to somebody's place
playing games assuming that you want you
only married
do i want to be married i've seen this
one do you want to have children
yes i'm in um i already have one right
now maybe one more
okay do you want to have to work
to pay bills after you're pregnant i
mean no
what state do you live in i live in
miami
he does well then god damn it think of
him as being superman going to the
fortress of solitude if you don't get
off my phone
now let me tell you what i'm calling in
so when i heard yeah you call in to put
the
put the girls on the camera
i was calling in because i was like
maybe i need to up that you know
that restraint on him traveling doing
his travel you know which no no no no
you think you get a better man by
putting restraints on them you restrain
your kids
you don't restrain no man that's how
they act
throw up some gang signs go ahead do it
[ __ ] walk for us
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you must unlearn what you have
learned
i'm sorry young lady how embarrassing
i'm sorry young lady are you trying to
let her know big shirley
she trying to let her know and she came
up here just still talking
i'll make you famous oh my god
i'm just gonna yeah i'm just uh
yeah and she just like and she just
won't go
her daughter should have told her one
[ __ ]
[Music]
i should take that b word out you look
at her she knows
i'm just stay here for about 15 minutes
of fame i did my hair for this
girl i did my hair i put on my best
v-neck t-shirt to be on the kevin sammy
show
um i did i put my hair up
in a puff or a poof or a bump or hump in
the bump
i put on my best v-neck t-shirt
i put on my uh chuck taylor's yeah
i'm looking like a queen diva oh yes
oh my god leave her oh
i don't i don't know what what led up to
this but i'm like leave her alone
out queen she's your queen
oh my god beauty and perfection
he probably looking down from heaven
like thank you lord jesus you got me out
of that [ __ ]
thank you thank you thank you i rebuke
people like thank you jesus for bringing
me home
thank you thank you thank you did i just
see where she at
bring it back where's the kitty yum yum
yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum
yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum
yum yum yum yum
and she gonna stay and hold on cause i'm
gonna fight you sucker
see she grew up on fred sanford and uh
this is pointless but uh i will tell you
this
you made my day what was your husband
say about this did y'all discuss it
no i'm not married i don't i would not
choose i would not choose to date into
something like that i got choose to be
single okay i'm a phd
okay congratulations but that was
unnecessary right
nope no no no you just know ma'am you
did i just asked you about marriage so i
just asked you about marriage and you
juxtaposed it against your education yes
sounds like that's trying to give you
context that's unnecessary i'm giving
you context about the practice that's
unnecessary
according to your way of thinking so i
asked you simply what did
okay you're not married what did your
boyfriend and or the man in your life
say about this
say about what specifically this
conversation because you're having it
with me so i'm assuming you had it with
him
yeah i mean he definitely does not think
that it was an appropriate
uh way of communicating around there's a
lot of men but uh he's in here okay
would he mind getting on with you uh
he's in here i don't know if he
emanuel are you on here
are you your height
your height oh no no five six
don't do it don't do it
um i'm a little bit like our size a
little
on the thick side so first um dress
don't up she's she's bigger than a 12.
how much you weigh the last time you
weighed yourself
about 170. [ __ ]
[ __ ] i thought the same thing
where's the last time you weighed
yourself junior high
and why this is relevant man i'm sitting
here trying to talk to a woman
who says you make over six figures
oh yeah i'm gonna still talk about you
this is why
this is why it matters you should have
stayed because it would have been easier
but now it's gonna be even worse
you call in on it to talk on the show
don't even know the topic
you come in here mumbling about stuff
and i'm trying to talk to you
then listen to what she said i would
somebody for two years and i couldn't be
because of covet and at the end of the
day
get right down to it she's that that
woman still wanted a man making over six
figures
dang that woman
don't get mad at me because men are
getting frustrated with the caliber and
quality
of women there's to pick from
i don't bash women i don't do anything i
just talk to women and
let them tell what they who who they are
and if some of the women
are not what you think the best
representation of women are
then take it up with the women because
what the men are going to tell you
is women like her are far more the norm
than women who are suitable and fit and
ready for a relationship
to the point to where people ask me are
these paid actors no these are just
what's walking around
oh my gosh i brought a friend to react
to a kevin samuels video one time and
that was what she said she asked if
they're actually this is what men have
to pick from
but then when they got a little i don't
know
i'm not dead i'm just gonna leave hope
you went up you left and i hope your ass
went to the gym
oh my gosh he does not hold back i'm
like not even gonna lie to you he does
not hold back
um that was a pretty funny compilation
let me know
in the comments if you guys have a kevin
samuels clip or a different clip that
you want me to react to next time
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification
bell i'll talk to you guys next time